qatar's foreign minister has been
holding talks in afghanistan with the
taliban leadership muhammad bin abdul
rahman atani is the most senior official
from any country to visit since the
group's takeover charles stratfor is
live for us in kabul
charles obviously qatar has been playing
a crucial role in terms of getting
people out of afghanistan and getting
aid in over the last couple of weeks
there seems to be another step in the
relationship but he's been talking to
both sides
that's correct rob yes as you say this
is the first time we've seen an
international foreign dignitary come and
meet um officially and meet uh members
of the interim taliban government we
understand the qatar foreign minister
met with the interim prime minister mula
hassan akund as well as as you mentioned
interestingly the former president hamad
karzai and abdullah abdullah
who of course was the former chief
executive officer of afghanistan and
somebody who played such a vital role
in those peace negotiations over the
last couple of years
there have been a couple of tweets with
respect to
what is being reported as to what was
discussed in those meetings according to
a local
news agency here in kabul they're saying
that
there are a number of important issues
including bilateral relations that
were discussed and interestingly a tweet
from the taliban spokesperson
in doha sahil shaheen he said that these
talks had also involved discussions of
about attracting more humanitarian
assistance of course we know
that the countries have been very much a
linchpin between
the new taliban government um and the
international community in trying to
come to some sort of resolution with
respect to
beginning to end this crisis
something that the humanitarian
world the u.n describes as potentially
being a humanitarian catastrophe
at the moment it's all about getting as
much aid into this country as possible
uh the un saying that um if indeed that
assistance doesn't arrive soon we could
be looking at uh 98 to 100 of this
population around 38 million people
potentially being under the poverty line
by next year so we can uh we can
understand that these discussions
obviously are very important um
and and potentially will have a huge
impact on millions of lives uh inside
afghanistan and a lot of that
international aid dependent on how the
taliban the interim government of the
taliban deals with issues like women's
rights for example and the inclusion of
minorities do we have any more
information about how they might deal
with that in the future
thus far with respect to positions for
women in the interim government or a
future permanent government no
indication of any change there there are
no women of any who hold any portfolios
thus far we heard from the taliban today
with respect to education the education
of women they are saying that women are
free to attend universities and schools
but certainly with respect to tertiary
or edge
university education there must be a
separation of the sexes inside
classrooms we understand that may well
involve some sort of curtain for example
in rooms to keep men and women apart but
of course yeah the international
community is looking for proof that the
taliban sticks to its commitments with
respect to human rights with respect to
for example the freedom of the media as
i say more inclusion of ethnic
minorities in any
permanent government more inclusion of
women
the promise that afghanistan will not be
used by armed groups to launch attacks
on foreign countries
and until according to the international
community thus far that sort of proof
is is given by the taliban then of
course they are holding back billions of
dollars of aid and afghan assets that
are frozen for example in u.s banks or
by the world bank
and it is vital um as we've heard from
the countries uh trying to galvanize a a
a a united
international response to this
humanitarian crisis that some sort of
agreement is made
by the un um
by the international community in order
for this aid to come through immediately
because as i say the the united nations
some of the predictions they're making
are very dire indeed unless this
humanitarian assistance starts coming
into this country soon
charles thanks very much indeed that's
charles stratford live in kabul
marman karbalan is head of policy
analysis at the arab center for research
and policy studies he explains qatar's
role in the rebuilding of afghanistan
under taliban rule
i think this is somehow a continuation
of qatar's active role in the afghan
issue
you know it started uh
actually a few years ago and it uh it
ended with the agreement on the u.s
withdrawal of afghanistan now the qatar
is continuing this role by trying
actually to reach out to taliban and try
to bridge this gap actually between
taliban and the international community
qatar is trying to make taliban like
more flexible more
responsive to the demands of the
international community concerning the
formation of the government concerning
the role of women in politics and
society
concerning the role of of minorities in
afghanistan all these things actually
would make it easier perhaps for qatar
to convince the international community
that taliban has changed and that it's
time perhaps to deal with it as the
legitimate government of afghanistan i
believe this is what qatar is trying to
do right now taliban is very sensitive
to
any sort of interference in the
afghan internal affairs especially now
taliban feels like it won this conflict
and it fought and won this conflict over
the past 20 years but i think we can
also on the other hand say that qatar
has some sort of a leverage over a
taliban because as you said the qatar is
trying actually to make this quid pro
approach with the taliban that if you
show some flexibility in terms of the
demands of the international community
we will be able actually to get you some
aid because at the end of the day
taliban would want actually to rule the
country the war is over now and you have
to rule the country right now and if you
want to rule the country without having
much troubles you need to have some sort
of international cooperation in helping
you out
to rule the country